call the art gallery because we have a beautiful
painting here this is simply
fantastic you have witnessed
history by Blackwood as burrow sends it to
declair on a breakway SC Anthony duclair
comes back to New York and puts the Sharks up
one to nothing burs makes a defensive play in
his own Zone he locates duclair in behind the
defense throws it out there what a handle by
duclair and this is the exact same move he used
last night on the Breakaway cm likes that puck
settles it down and he gets it to the [Applause]
[Music] forand Simon holr off the turnover he's
dangerous has two short in to goal and he
hits the crossbar in and that will tie him
with Logan o Conor for the NHL lead shorthanded
he intercepts the Pucket little Tic Tac given
go with JG Paso and Holstrom comes in on the back
hand this is the beauty up over the shoulder in a
breakway oh baby what a pass by Marty NES to
Stephan Nathan unselfish probably could have
went backand shelf just drop it just take a tap in
my light and the little chip from n to make sure
that comry doesn't make a spectacular low save but
you think about NIS hasn't scor sometime he could
have taken that to the house completely unselfish
un especially when you consider the circumstance
tonight Keller looking around Keller right through
they score what a pass look the silky Ms of number
nine head up little saucer pass up and down over
two if not three Washington Capital sticks and
right onto the twig of Logan [__] thank you
very much back door tapping and he's pointing at
Clayton Keller the for the air saved by whoo heasy
store just a real good job by EC to get a stick on
it I think it's good Jody it's below the crossbar
how about that one and then two it's almost like a
trick goal there for BC hand ey coordination and
the wherewithal slow motion you can appreciate
it as you're right that's at the crossbar or
below and that's a good goal what a goal for the
Rangers what a finish for BC back to Middleton a
penalty coming against Nashville Middleton scores
a backand or the Goes Pop sh felo with the feed to
Middleton ding the rush late beautiful play here
to the backand wide base quick little flip he's
got that big paddle rolls it off the heel to the
toe snaps it over the glove of Soros he's had a
lot of them here now more spinning shooting and he
scores there was absolutely no space Oh yes there
was spin he's going there just as his hands get in
front of the red line he releases there's no waste
of time there's no hesitation it's skill it's
power got it Tois got it to the front of scores
does that go between his legs I mean he's he's
facing the wrong way Le is just going to throw
this at the net now watch The Hand Eye he's going
to spin back between his legs what a goal first
of the year for Brock M again that is a big one
for Anaheim on for Robbie pavri right a goal
last night nice move there copy right in go
oh he scored what a play oh my goodness that's
a good example of playing the puck and not the
body and Robbie fabry made a pay did he undress
him or what I look at the big board there's a
jock trrap hanging on it and it belongs to
Kaiser oh my jari he's going for the empty
net bouncing towards the goal he scores you have
witnessed history Tristan jari becomes the first
goenda actually score a goal wow was
that with some authority too I mean
that thing was Sky down the ice I'll
tell you what that puck bounces the
first time on the hash marks there's
not not many goal tenders that can do
that AO wiggle and zaka scores host's ability to
freeze Defenders is paralyzed two an opponent nice
little move to the outside San Jose doesn't defend
the middle ice and it's basically just a simple
give and go get to the back end where I got tons
of Leverage throw it up over the left patent CL
and that's a nice Finish By Zach with the blues
for 10 here's a quick shot scores Benson right
off the face off rips it low and pass Bennington
cousins wins this draw Benson gets it here bang
he just spins fires it to the net leaves it right
on the ice it was perfectly placed the quick shot
and the smile on that young man right there he
knows that's a big goal here's gry the one they
score what a pass by granin over the defenseman
duclair just a quick one time shot and buries it
on Schmid but Zin really sets this up on the
physical play deep inside the defensive Zone
oh you talk about a guy who needed a goal it's
Anthony Clair and a pass for duclair he scored
the dke is loose what a move by duclair cutting
over to his back hand then back to the forehand
and barries on a beautiful little move second of
the night and second huge assist for mik grin and
that was Perfection the pass the de and then the
finish by Anthony duclair valard interesting to
see how when he settles in he is on the foul
play and he sets up stly look at valard as he
protects it uses his big body that's just slick
Miss it's like the puck is a yo-yo off of his
blade he can string it out and suck it back
in and he did right there a little one touch
pass good for shley to go to the puck and then
he doesn't dust It Off Top quarters it up with
the who to Toronto as the B sticks the STI in
the Leaf's heart went in alone he tried to go
five hole on the back end when it wasn't there
he did not curl away Marsh able to SL it down
what an effort by Boston drives it around the
net drops it back to Stone and scores doesn't
get much better than that kich going to curl
has everybody following that Long Reach no look
backhand pass and Stone from a tough angle to the
back of the net as the captain gets his seventh
off an incredible feed from Mel is power play
brought to you by your triy Volkswagen dealers
Lee scores tapped in through the legs of Anders
Lee and Anthony stolar how you talk about the
importance faceoffs and you never underestimate
the value of that it gives you see this face off
good win watch the puck movement as Anders Lee
stays right in front Quick Pass I love the play
by Andrew LE Smith comes up with got siss with
him finds him that's Yakov Tran right in front
redirects it in for a two nothing lead sis just
gets this box there's no bones about it right
here he's going to get this puck back Cole Smith's
going to get it to break to the net trenin right
front of Luc and he tips it again tough play there
for lcan and he's had two goals and not much of a
chance on either takes it drops it back shle to
Conor to shley Center heers top shell goal the
movement of this pu goes Conor eers between the
legs to shley oh yeah I'll just drop it back to
Conor back to shley and eers does such a great
job here rather than rushing towards the net
he Paces himself back to the high slot where
there is no coverage he gets it on and off to
stick in a hurry with great accuracy that is a
thing of Pino in for Minnesota cuts to the slot
off the post while slamming their sticks on the
wall they think that Felino shot found the back
of the net what a move by Marcus Felino to get
inside the paint that did look to me like it hit
the back of the net up here from the crust box
that hit just to The Back Bar there and caught
the padding that's why it didn't make a sound
like a ping oh it hit the post first then the
middle part man he really got a lot of wood on
that puck still in play L get shot score holy
sniky what a shot from ly that puck might have
been Airborne when he ripped it puck pops out to
lurin and he absolutely fires this one one time
see to go down to that one knee get the leverage
but Buffalo definitely stops thinks there should
be a whistle there is it and it's in the back of
their neck and Al to Skinner back hand SK Detroit
does a great job cutting this ice in half keeping
buffalo on the right side but Dage Thompson back
in the lineup great job protecting it and these
are the battles Buffalo has to win they did it
on their last goal they continue to do it here
skner comes up with that puck what a move to his
backhead and it's a big Power Play Gold [Music]
he